and good evening to you all eyes on
nevada tonight as votes are still being
counted here and across the country
as the presidential race remains too
close to call
thank you for joining us on 8 news down
5 i'm brian loftus and i'm denise valdez
election day has certainly turned into
election week as it could be days now
before we know the official
winner all right so late this afternoon
michigan was called for biden
our producer was giving me some
instructions but i was talking i
couldn't hear
seems like the electoral college map is
on hold we're going to get to that in a
second but we can see that uh
the the race in nevada so significantly
close separated by just
8 000 really 7 500 votes and again we'll
be
continuing to keep an eye on it as is
the rest of the country as nevada
has really become a pivotal battleground
state
in the race for president now we
continue our team coverage with joe
moller and vanessa murphy
where results stand in our state vanessa
we're hearing new results
may not come in at all tonight what
exactly can you tell us
okay well first we were told by the
secretary of state's office that we
would receive an
update tomorrow morning then the deputy
secretary of state for elections told me
we'd receive an
update this afternoon now he's saying he
made a mistake that he shouldn't have
said that he apologized
he made the commitment without knowing
that that could happen so
no additional results from nevada
today or tonight now so you might be
wondering
why is nevada with being a smaller state
taking so long for results well
wayne thorley points to assembly bill 4
which required that all
active registered voters be sent a
mail-in ballot
they can still be counted if postmarked
by election day
voters have up to nine days after the
election to confirm signatures were
theirs if their ballot was rejected
thorley says there was a record number
of mail-in ballots received
as we've been reporting final election
results in nevada weren't
expected on election night so here's
what wayne thorley said
earlier about releasing results today
but again this
ended up changing every time a county
sends us results it takes
staff away from actually counting
ballots so we were trying to be
efficient and methodical in the process
but also recognize
you know people want to know so we're
looking at doing an
update later this afternoon with some
additional mail ballots counted
so you can see some confusion there more
results
now expected tomorrow another point we
touched on voter fraud president donald
trump has said the election would be
stolen in nevada and made
claims about voter fraud i asked thorley
about that
he says there have maybe been a handful
of allegations in nevada that are being
investigated i asked him for more of a
specific number
he said less than 10 but again he
stressed
there is no evidence of widespread voter
fraud so again i want to stress
no additional results in nevada today
we just learned reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now
yeah they've gone back on 4th for sure
on that today vanessa so today the clark
county register voters held a news
conference this afternoon to talk about
the process that's going on here in
southern nevada
let's check in with joe mohler with what
we can expect on
update on results hi there joe
well we're outside the election center
here in north las vegas we're in a press
conference we did learn that we will not
get any new information as far as
results go until
tomorrow morning at another press
conference like we've been mentioning
when nearly 1.2 million votes have been
processed so far but the counting is
continuing
here in clark county now as of yesterday
the election department
counted all of the early votes early
balance that is and all of the in-person
election day balance
what is left are male provisional and
electronic ballots sent to residents
overseas now the clark county registrar
voters joe gloria said they are able to
process 70 thousand votes a day
tomorrow at 10 a.m we'll be prepared to
report all of the counts for
what we received through the mail ballot
drop-off what we received in yesterday's
u.s mail and today's u.s mail
the presidential race is still too close
to call with what has been processed it
is hard to say how many outstanding
ballots are left due to the fact that
every resident was
sent one now those must be postpartum
november third and will be counted
through next week sort of like how
vanessa was mentioning there now gloria
said there were issues with a few voting
machines and a handful of observers who
had to be removed but
nothing major when it comes to problems
now that press conference will be
happening outside the election center
here tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
and in the days that follow there'll be
more press conferences as posts continue
to be counted
reporting live in north las vegas john
muller eight news okay
10 a.m tomorrow we can text everyone
who's asking us right we know you're
getting a question too
let's check it now with the congress
races congresswoman dina titus likely
will
hold her seat expected to be a dominant
win 61-34 percent
that is exactly what is happening
district two
congressman mark amade is leading also
significantly 57 to 41 percent
over patricia ackerman now distant three
this was highly contested it is close
susie lee with a one point lead 48 to 47
percent
over dan rodimer congressman horsford
also as we see a slight lead three
points 50 to 47 percent
over the challenger jim rashant so
keeping those numbers in mind eight news
now is also keeping a close eye on the
balance of power in carson city
democrats right now controlling both the
state senate and the state assembly but
they actually appear to be losing some
of that control
i-team reporter david charns takes a
look at the balance of power he joins us
now live
in studio david yeah so we are waiting
for more of these results to come in
it's going to affect these races but
this is how the balance of power skus
right now this was a great night for
republicans here in nevada
looks like they gained seats in the
state senate if the election were called
right now
democrats would lose one or two seats
probably an 11 to 10 balance of power
switching over to the nevada state
assembly right now
it would probably be about 26 democrats
to 16 republicans again these races
just not all counted yet but again they
still have control democrats still have
control but no longer
a super majority likely down to 26-16
let's drill down to some of these local
races where you are in senate district
six
this is in northwest las vegas this is
the state senate majority
leader nicole canazzaro she likely will
lose her seat this is the state leader
to her republican opponent april beck
but still too close to call you see
there
50 50. district 5 is an open seat in
henderson right now that is leading
republican as well
kerry buck and we are awaiting a good
chunk of those clark county votes to
decide that one as well this
one also we're going to state assembly
district 2 a closer look at those races
republican heidi kasama leading her
opponent here by
several points right now district 4
republican richard macarthur running
ahead of democratic incumbent connie
monk
to district 31 that's in washoe county
democrat
skip daley losing right now to his
republican challenger
jill ann dickman and district 37 shea
bacchus likely losing her seat to andy
matthews now
review journal political editor and
channel 8 political analyst steve
stabilius
tells us this means democrats won't be
able to push as much through the state
house
he also says this means that they'll
have to make some concessions
much like a lot of these results you see
things
uh you know that are uh 50 to 49
51.84 to 48.6
that is the country right now a lot of
these races mimicking what we're seeing
across the country and losing that super
majority in carson city
also means democrats will need
bipartisan support passing any new taxes
keep in mind though even with these
results this was not a gubernatorial
election
and with the governorship both chambers
of the state house democrats remain in
pretty firm control here i'm david
charns 8 news now
david thank you 8 news now is your local
election headquarters we have loaded up
on coffee and will be in this until the
end stay with us for the latest results
you can find them anytime
at eightnewsnow.com